i mean when i look at it it looks to me
constantly as though the politicians are
making it up as they go
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
frances foster i'm constantly kissing
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations
with fascinating people our fantastic
guest today
is a consultant oncologist and a
professor of medicine at the university
of buckingham
professor karen sikora welcome to
chicken amateur thank you very much
it's a great pleasure to have you here
you covert 19 has obviously been a huge
factor in the life of this country and
in fact the world in the last
in the last few months before we get
into that tell everybody a little bit
about who are you
uh what's been your background how are
you uh here today
so i'm an oncologist someone that treats
cancer with chemotherapy and
radiotherapy
and uh did medicine went straight into
academic medicine oncology and went to
the states for a couple of years at
stanford fantastic
experience in the states came back here
and i've been a consultant in the nhs
for 40 years
i started young as a consultant now i'm
very old so i've been through the whole
thing
and then of course covid came out of
nowhere i'm really out of nowhere
in february you can see it building up i
said it's not going to happen
nothing's going to happen it's all back
to normal by easter
and of course we know it wasn't back to
normal it's kind of getting
continuing now here we are in the autumn
the leaves are turning brown and we're
still dealing with cobia daily
i said myself it's just the flu so i
know how you feel
but um the thing we really wanted to ask
you about this
there's a thing that's been bothering us
and we exchanged some emails and we
talked about this which is that
it seems like the consequences of the
lockdown
are not being given as much weight and
attention as the consequences of the
coronavirus itself
so people don't seem to be thinking
about the fact that
the lockdown leads to economic problems
and economic problems lead to social
problems to medical problems to health
issues
and it are we right to feel that that
those consequences are not being
properly looked at when we consider the
balance of the actions that are being
taken
i mean when i look at it it looks to me
constantly as though the politicians are
making it up as they go
they don't have a long-term strategy and
nor do they
they're advisors probably too many
advisors these sage committees will hear
about 40 or 50 people
they like to get consent if you have a
committee wants to get consensus i've
seen it in the nhs over the years they
want consensus so
you don't really get leadership you just
get a sort of democracy of votes
and then people discuss and then you all
go down one route
and it changes it's like watching birds
flying around in groups and swarms of
birds and they suddenly change direction
and they all go
the other way and that's what we've been
seeing with this and
whether the decisions at different time
points are going to prove the correct
ones you won't
really ever know i mean you summarized
it well there's the
the health there's the economic economy
but there's also
cobia versus other helps and that's sort
of been forgotten about
it you know that that was the reason
that i joined twitter to try and point
out look hey we can't stop
everything we can't stop cancer being
creature and not only that we can't stop
the diagnostic process for cancer so
uh what's really important is to think
of it covid
is one box other house is another box
and
but if you spend a lot of time on cover
you won't have the other box for
other specialties and not just cancer
but heart disease mental health all
these things
and then at the other end you've got the
economy which loops around
back into health because social
destruction fabric unemployment
mental health poverty deprivation child
abuse they're all connected in that
it's not they're not isolated and so
ruin the economy
and you'll get not different health
problems
and carol we we we've been talking about
covid
and the at the start there was a the
stat of
half a million people are going to die
if we don't do something
how dangerous is it as a disease is it
as some people say that it's
for most people it's absolutely fine do
you risk long-term complications if you
get it
how virulent is it that is the great
puzzle francis so if you take the cruise
ships they were the best studies
uh the cruise ship and there was an
aircraft carrier a
a french aircraft carrier and an
american battleship
all got infected roughly the same
statistics
uh high levels of infection thousands of
people on
the ships got infected very few people
died
and the cruise ship that was stuck in
yokohama harbor if you remember in
april of this year it was a luxury
cruise ship and the average age of the
the customers was 72.
so these are old people and yet there
were very few deaths something like 10
deaths altogether
out of 700 people infected not only that
you've got people that get infected
clearly when they have a
pcr test or the virus is present the
virus genomic materials present
and yet they've got no symptoms at all
no fever no shortness of breath
nothing no loss of smell and and taste
which are the key features of clothing
and yet they've definitely been infected
so it's a huge puzzle
and the real problem for public health
normally you go chasing
the disease so if you take cholera you
look for people with diarrhea you
isolate them you make the
family wash their hands you go to the
source of where they're eating from the
drinking from and try and
see what where the cholera was coming
from they're ill
before they get the infection and then
they become ill
with this you get infected and you don't
become ill in many cases so it's very
difficult to go tracing it
and so you do have to have in fact a
good
test for the disease what we've seen
just this morning
matt hancock has announced that he's
going to enlarge the testing program
you know this should have been done
three months ago you really want to find
out where it is but
we do see things have changed they've
definitely changed since we started in
april
um the peak was obviously march then
peaked in april in terms of if severity
of disease
now people are not going to hospital and
it's a
slightly younger age group that's being
infected but we're testing everybody the
more you chest the more you find and so
especially if you target your testing so
if you go to hotspots you go to
leicester you go to oldham rather than
places like that knock on doors
shall sticks up people's noses much more
likely to be positive
yeah now and also if we convert to the
saliva chest and we just tested all our
stuff with saliva testing just yesterday
for the first time
that is a such an easy way of doing it
because it's not at all intrusive it
doesn't have any
uh ethical issues uh you know people
don't like having the stick up their
nose and it requires
someone you don't have so much skill to
do it but you have to be able to do it
and the other risks of sticking
sticks up people's noses they splutter
at you and they're affected and they're
spluttering this is not good for you
so you have to wear some sort of
protective clothing and that looks
frightening especially for children so
collecting a piece of a sample of spit
into a tube is a lot less
invasive basically and one of the
questions that i wanted to ask is
obviously as we ramp up the testing one
of the things we are doing is uncovering
lots of people as you say
who have been infected who we weren't
aware of before
is is is one of the consequences of that
not an
indication that this disease is a lot
less lethal than we thought
absolutely and the fact you know
hospitalization is the key to death
because if you don't get admitted to
hospital you're unlikely to die that's
usually how
sure there have been deaths at home and
care homes and so on but
most people that die go to a hospital
most people not only go to hospital
the ones that are going to die go to
intensive care and then they die
so that's the pathway so if no one's
going into hospital
that means something's different there's
several explanations for that the nice
explanation which i'd like is that the
virus wants to be kind to us
that sounds like medically verifiable
it's got a little white flag you know
it's
waving a little on the end of those
little spikes that you can see in the
kids diagrams
you've got a little white flag saying i
want to be friends but evolutionary wise
that's not a bad strategy for the virus
that means it will stay with us forever
now we may not like the sound of that
but you know the common cold virus is
staying with us forever and we've
adapted to it the flu virus is staying
with us and we've adapted
why not coronavirus ii a coronavirus one
which is the sars
virus way back from 2003 17 years ago
it's still around even though it doesn't
trouble society and that's the great
puzzle how these viruses
can insert themselves into us you know
i tried to involve philosopher at oxford
on the philosophy why does the virus
exist
he wasn't too interested
does the virus have a soul can it tell
between good and evil and all this sort
of stuff
of course not it's a little bag the
simplest form of life
um well and even whether it's alive or
dead is contentious
i think it's alive it it borrows life
it's on its own it doesn't do anything
it's in a bunch of chemicals
once it gets into a cell it hijacks
living processes that we have to become
alive basically
and then it comes out again and reverts
to being dead just i know people like
that
yeah you're talking about me but
but carol uh just so the
just for people watching at home uh who
are not medical experts
compared to let's say the common the flu
which kills a lot of people as as we now
discover
most medical professionals of course
would have known that anyway but
ordinary people don't think of the flu
as this great killer but it does kill a
lot of particularly old and vulnerable
people every winter especially
compared to the flu the coronavirus as
it is now
is it more lethal less lethal about the
same do we have any sort of idea about
that it's about the same
and that's the problem with it all you
know and uh
the other thing we haven't come to yet
is vaccination yes we have a vaccine for
the flu
but it's never very good no it's 50
effective and we make a lot of fuss some
people have it some people
don't uh and you know if you're over 60
you get it free for healthcare
professional
you get it free and uh if you're
vulnerable as a young person if you're
your young age you'd also get it free
but we forget the through kills more
people than
this has killed this year and it doesn't
but it doesn't happen
in quite the same way the other
similarity is the age difference that
you you know that flu like covid too
is an age related that the average age
of someone that's died
this year with covert is 82 so that's
the average
82 82 exactly it's the same with flu
younger people 70 year olds they get
over it
it's people with bad lungs previous
infections
that die from flu in hospital that don't
respond to the antibiotics basically
happens every winter and we accept that
flu is winter related that's one of the
big differences cobia
is not it seems to go just even
throughout the year
so as we go into winter now
the biggest worry is that we get a
second wave i don't believe there will
be but
it's just imagine you get a big spike of
uh infection around the country
at the same time you get the flu and so
you get people with chest infections
you can't tell the difference you've got
older people some with copies some with
pneumonia because of the flu and you'll
start with a whole lot of patients and
the nhs shuts down and that's the
disaster and there was a very gloomy
prediction report from say
two weeks ago predicting 85 000 deaths
in the second wave
and uh moving into winter pressures and
you know the top excellence of the nhs
um they have to plan for that sort of
scenario you have to plan for it which
would involve
closing down cancer and everything again
it would also mean for society closing
down a lot of other things schools
shops pubs the rest of it and of course
that would have huge economic
disaster if we had to shut down again so
i think you know that's the disaster
scenario which epidemiologists like
by the way from ferguson downwards
ferguson was the half a million deaths
predictor at the beginning
and so neil ferguson uh and his
colleagues he was slightly distracted
when he was working and as we now know
that their importance depends on how
gloomy they can be
right if a politician hears he's going
to have half a million deaths to answer
for he's going to wake up and say okay
come in here tell me what i have to do
if you said no it'll blow it will only
be 40 000 it'll all blow over and
they'll be 82
above anyway and you know all this sort
of thing apologies well that's not too
bad we'll just ride with it so
it's it's it's very difficult um and
i've noticed the the epidemiologists
love it they they
they phrase the whole thing this is not
a prediction
this just could happen and i remember
seeing a very funny
of a funny cartoon where you know it's
got
four boxes and the first boxes um
you know predict the gloom uh
i'm wrong they they cheer they say i've
saved you from the gloomy prognosis
if it happens i'll totally say that
that's what happens if you predict
no gloom it's all going to be okay and
it goes bad you're fired yeah
so uh what can an epidemiologist do
they're just body counters basically so
it's it's a very strange scenario so the
doctors the actual treatment doctors
like me
say come on you can't do that you've got
to be more realistic and
otherwise the implication of gloomy
epidemiology is you shut things down you
build
nightingale hospitals completely
wasteful in terms of money
and not thought so obviously we'll talk
about the second wave potentially and
the second lockdown
but let me just get something clear in
my head because
i have a confusion that i know from
listening to our viewers
is shared by many people which is this
we were told
that the first lockdown the purpose of
the first lockdown
was protect the nhs
crush the sombrero whatever boris
johnson said right
and it's about preventing the nhs from
being overwhelmed
we achieved that overwhelmingly the nhs
is not overwhelmed the nightingale
hospitals which you
just mentioned were essentially unused
saw almost no patience at the moment
the numbers of people in hospital as you
say are very very low
and yet we continue to have what you
might describe as quite restrictive
measures
people wearing masks indoors social
distancing there's certain things that
you can't do
etc etc if the rationale for the for all
of these measures was to protect the nhs
why are we still doing all of this stuff
no it was to start with there's no doubt
before easter
easter was about the 8th of april and
as we came up the worry was what
happened to italy
the the health service nearly got
overwhelmed it sort of
it was overwhelmed there was
prioritization of younger versus older
people in intensive care and so on
we never got overwhelmed here there was
one hospital declared an emergency in
northwest london northwest park hospital
and that's just a redistribution too
many people pitched up in the emergency
room at the same time
it's easy to solve you just go somewhere
else you take them in ambulances
somewhere else
and so that was solved the problem we've
got is that the problem then was
you couldn't predict what was going to
happen and so and the logo the
the the strap line of you know
protect the nhs save lives stay home
uh was the lines that frightened
everybody that was the line to keep
people
and you know older people especially
were doing it because they thought they
were protecting
other people protect the nhs which
implies protect
them and of course cancer patient can
come forward
during that period of april and may 45
reduction in the number of people having
heart attacks now it can't be that it
was a 45 percent reduction
it just that no one came because they
suffered chest pain and didn't do
anything about it
the attendance the emergency room if
anything was dropped
to 50 percent is what it normally is
that's because people won't go down on
saturday night
they don't want to get out there yeah
knife fights yeah drug deals
but as you move forward uh now
it's about trying to protect the whole
system
from uh winter pressures coming because
the same measures of social distancing
hand washing
mask wearing protect you from other
infections like flu so
it's a bit of both now the real truth
constantly
nobody knows what's going to happen
neither me as an oncologist
and not the epidemiologist nor the my
infectious disease colleagues they
really don't know what's going to happen
and to me there are really three options
now the virus has got
it can fizzle out which is a great
option we all want a fizzler here we
want it just to go weak
and learn to live with us and we'll just
cope with it and that's fine
the second option it has is local spikes
and that's what we're seeing which
are politically quite damaging because
you know you get this rivalry in
scotland wales northern ireland and
trying to show that they're coping
better and so on
and you you know when we do see a local
outbreak
it's not like we're really doing that
drastic measures we may
make confusing rules you can't socially
go and visit grandma but you can go to a
pub with grandma
and have a meal in a pub so this is
makes no sense
and what you really have to do if you
really believe
in in public health strategy you have to
shut the town down you have to
cut off the roads put roadblocks around
it close the railway station
so that's it that's
and what they did in italy yeah the
police roadblocks everywhere you
couldn't go from north to southern italy
yes so no you go back
uh and we haven't done that anywhere
golden
and all these other places met all the
manchester suburbs that are hot
so uh the third thing for the virus is
the full-blown
second wave when it really comes back
the
higher peak that you can't squash with
hospital admissions
intensive care flooding the system now
it's clear that nobody really believes
that third option is going to happen
and it probably is between the two
fizzling out with a few local spikes and
we can cope with that
and it's the same pattern around europe
the difficulty
is how serious you have to take things
like
you know beginning of this week i
remember seeing
the story about the zanchi and the
chewie flight that came from zanchi to
the covenant church at cardiff and
11 people were infected on it testing
positive
what do you do about that you suddenly
close down grease you make quarantine
for everybody is
it's very difficult there's no right or
wrong answer
my own feeling is you just ignore it and
you just leave it carol what i'm getting
at and i think this is a question in a
lot of people's minds is
you've said that the average age of
death for a patient a covert patient in
this country
82. we had a period which was the summer
and late spring yeah
when the nhs was not overwhelmed
are we not overreacting with everything
that that we're being forced to do
particularly given that
there's a cost to the reaction yeah the
the cancer people who are not coming in
to get a diagnosis the heart attacks
that are going untreated
mental health alcohol abuse drug abuse
child abuse all of these things
are exacerbated by people being forced
to isolate there's a lack of
communication between different
generations
all of these things cause a problem have
we not overreacted
i think we have and i think we've if
you've taken it as a doctor we've
certainly overreacted
and putting too much emphasis in health
care on covid and
removing it from the other things in
terms of the economy
i think we've already discussed the fact
that economy and health are intertwined
you can't separate the two
and if the economy goes down the tubes
then even people that are currently
in deprivation areas are going to be
worth worse off they're not going to be
healthier they're not going to
carol there's a question that i really
wanted to ask you so you're an
oncologist you're a cancer specialist
what effect has this had on people
having cancer treatments people being
diagnosed with cancer
what are the real world implications of
this so for people with cats that we've
known at the beginning say you had
cancer in april
has it really impacted we've tried to
minimize the impact so if you're on
chemotherapy or radiotherapy you got it
if you're about to have surgery
except in the period in march and early
april most people
got it the biggest impact which
is still ongoing is on people that have
got symptoms they've gone to the doctor
and they haven't really been got into a
diagnostic pathway so
you only diagnose cancer by taking a
little bit of tissue
called biopsy from wherever the cancer
is four common areas breast lung
prostate
and colon so you've got to get in that
which
means doing some technique some image
ultrasound
ct scan mr scan and there's been a
complete
shutdown of all the diagnostic pathways
for far too long now first three months
you could perhaps
excuse but some of them are still not
operating as normal
one estimate last week suggests that 15
million people
were actually waiting for a diagnostic
test the problem is
a lot of people have diagnostic tests
and only a small proportion of that
goodness
have cancer but we don't know which they
are in there so
um if you take ct scans you screen maybe
100 people
and only 12 or 13 will actually have
cancer in there but
there's no way of prioritizing them
that's so we've tried to fast-track
people with cancer-like symptoms but
it's not like
that the other problem for the nhs which
is peculiar to this country
is that it's under-capacitized anyway
for diagnostic tests so
in france if you need a ct scan because
you've got a cough or
coughed up a bit of blood you'll get it
by next week it'll all be sorted out by
next
here you may take three months and
that's normally that was 2019 before all
this happened
and so now because of the huge backlog
if you
have cancer but don't know it it's going
to take longer to
diagnose and the danger in that is it
gives cancer the opportunity to spread
and whilst we're very good at treating
localized cancer in the four main organs
but
anywhere else you have it we're not so
good if the disease starts spreading the
outcome the prognosis goes down and the
treatment gets
more difficult more arduous for the
patient so
chemotherapy radiotherapy immunotherapy
all these things which we can do
but the prognosis is much worse if the
cancer spreads out to the primary organ
and so
that's the impact of this five published
papers in the uk
looking at trying to quantitate that
impact
and they vary from twenty excess deaths
because of the delay to 50
000 excess deaths already and that's the
the worrying feature
and we're still not back to normal um
again our health minister said we were
nearly back to normal i would dispute
that if there are 15 million people
waiting for
this is not normal even in the nhs uh
you know there aren't 15 15 million
people in france waiting for a
diagnostic we've got to
we've really got to speed that whole
thing up and
the other thing of course it's not just
the big diseases we've
there's all sorts of other diseases that
we need to look at
i mean people children with deafness
they've just been ignored people with
uh you know things that we say well they
can just wait just put it on hold
uh deaf children for example that need
hearing assessment
people with painful hips painful knees
not urgent because they've had pain for
years they need a hip replacement
just they'll just have to wait the
waiting list at the best of times is
often more than a year anyway now it's
it's going to be two or three years
before they get
the nhs to get them the operations and a
lot of pain and suffering
is caused by the virus not directly but
the indirect effects on our health
service but
the number that i found staggering there
is you said that between 20 to 50
000 excess deaths as a result of the
virus purely from cancer is that correct
that's correct why is this not a bigger
scandal
i know i keep saying everybody it is a
scandal
and you know the the reason it's such a
variance that 20 how can you not know
whether it's twenty
000 or 100 or 50 000 and the reason is
the only way to know
will be next year when we look back on
it all you'll be able to look and see
how the cancer has behaved
yeah uh we can't do it now we can make
predictions and all these things are
predictions for delay so
if the delay is only one month it's not
going to make that much difference if
it's six months that'll be the other end
that'll be the fifty thousand day
and the twenty thousand is about four
months delay
uh all together the the mass of cancer
in this country are very simple there
are 360 000 new patients a year
at 30 000 a month and uh that means a
thousand a day
at the moment the cancer diagnostic rate
is running about half
of that so it's running at about 500 a
day so
it's not that the other 500 aren't
getting cancer
covert has suddenly prevented cancer and
everyone's being
not getting it it's just high that it's
hiding the fact because these people
haven't been able to get the diagnostic
necessary to work so
half the people who need to be tested
for cancer are not getting
well they're in the queue yeah but they
have they're not getting it now
they're not there now and they don't
know it of course so
that's the so certain things are picked
up so mammography
which are breasts yeah yeah that's
really picked up
and because it's simple it doesn't
generate any
uh aerosol there's no touching involved
necessarily so it can be done
that your your flow of patience isn't
affected by
at the other end you've got endoscopy
which involves putting a tube down in
the mouth or into the back passage but
down into the mouth people are going to
cough the splutter it generates aerosol
you've got to wear full protective
clothing to the operator
you've got to clean everything between
each patient disinfect the whole
place so instead of doing 10 endoscopies
of morning for example would be the
average endoscopy list you're down to
three or
four in the morning so and yet you've
got a backlog for
for four or five months backlog so it's
very difficult
a slow pace what's the solution well you
just have to work harder work longer
and do what it takes and and change the
processes you know
industry a pub has changed the way it
works it wants the revenue
um you know i'm a little bit uh in a
public private private sector is much
more efficient
going to change public sector has the
luxury of time
and the luxury well there's no incentive
to do anything
we can discuss the problem set up a
committee do a working party
write a few papers a piece of work in
paper in the nhs is not actually doing
anything
and once you've got that
you know what you need it's difficult to
get rid of the backlog
plus the fact the staff feel
you know during the whole code thing was
a lot of effort and it was
sort of i hate to say it but it was it
was fun it was different from normal
people pulled together it was a great
spirit
and they were recognized by the public
and all the heroes the banging of spoons
all that stuff great
that's all gone and so now people are
beginning to complain
they've been on a list they've been told
to come back next month and nothing's
happening
gps you know the problem there is a lot
of gps just shut up shop
and they don't like me when i say this
but it's true
some work through us but when you look
we have a health services primary care
base why didn't they take control
of the whole pandemic in reality all the
testing should be done in gp surgeries
it should be done in the
car parks of gp surgeries i mean why
should people go up to aberdeen if you
live in
sussex for a test to have a swab put in
your nose when there's a perfect network
of primary care doctors nurses
healthcare technicians in these places
so
i think that's that's probably what we
have to get back to and why is it that
it's now
taboo to criticize lockdown
to criticize the government's handling
of it to even say that maybe our
reaction was
overblown especially i think there's
numbers of the excess deaths
that you've just quoted i mean if we
were in a dictatorial state we'd all be
arrested
and then they'd be breaking the doors
down inside
would be at the gates up there and
breaking you down but but you say that
there's the footage of this pregnant
woman being arrested in australia for
i know i've seen it i i think that's the
over
over abuse of of power and i think
that's
on the whole in britain we've handled it
very i must say i think the police have
handled it as
well as they could you know we've not if
there was good footage it would
certainly be on mainstream media and we
haven't seen it
and uh and you know a few people got
arrested if you know
people in in uh with raves and so on no
one's too sympathetic about that what
you
do object to is you know there was one i
saw something right at the beginning
when we were in proper lockdown
some little old lady was made to open a
shopping bag at a police checkpoint to
see if she'd really been shopping i'm
not just seated
if you allow people to go shopping you
just have to assume they're going to
take their own responsibility where
they've really been shopping or gone to
visit someone it's
it's not policeable this whole thing and
i think that's the
that is an abuse of power and i'm sure
um
uh reading about a police that broke up
a child's birthday party yeah
this is just not what police want to do
you imagine your
hands up you're surrounded we've got
tear gas wagon
we've got water cannon we're going to
bust up the party
there's a little five-year-old girl in
tears this is not
how we handle it here and on the whole
it's been handled really well i think
the difficulty
is that the politicians maybe get a kick
out of power and it's a
taste of power you don't normally have
emergency regulations always give people
more power than the
public health guys the same imagine some
overzealous
overzealous public health inspector in
in a council
his moment of glory you can't put a
black cross on your door and that's it
you're finished you know even yesterday
at the hospital
i was going around the hot there was a
stroke mandeville hospital
and uh i was not wearing my mask
properly this is a confession i don't
want to make confessions on
tv and it was just after my nose was
visible
and this very nice uh
lady a nurse in her sister's uniform
came and showed me her card
infection control nurse i said yes your
mask is
not on your nose i just had to put it
back thank you
and she walked off i thought brilliant
imagine if she could
get you know you are surrounded put your
mask on you'll be arrested
well you see we joke about it but
sometimes in my more paranoid moments i
think are we gonna
are we are we gonna arrive at that point
no i think we're gonna get out of it
before we get there now
well let's talk about that because
you've said repeatedly that uh
doesn't you don't think there's gonna be
a second wave isn't isn't there some
evidence that this is or a seasonal
disease that is likely to make a
comeback or
have all the people who are going to
sort of get it and die from it already
got it and died from it
well all the two things are are
the main bulk of vulnerable people
already suffered
and gone and that's one thing and the
second thing
is the virus changing to be more
immediable to live with us
and not to cause severe infection uh
cause the lung damage that results in
death of via intensive care units and so
on
so we really just don't know and
time will tell the next few weeks are
critical
as we increase testing and as we
increase risk
schools going back does increase the
risk but you know
it's the first weeks too early to tell
we'll know by the end of next week
how many schools have had to shut
because of it hopefully none and then as
we go forward as more and more offices
open especially in london we'll see
if you look at the last few weeks
london's become if you just take london
because
that's where we are now but i'm sure
it's the same for all major cities
um it's opened up and we've not seen
any change and nothing's happened
basically certainly the emergency rooms
are empty which is the best indicator of
severe disease so i think we're gonna go
forward with that
now we've kept mentioning we may as well
talk about it now i guess the second
wave concept yes
the second wave comes from influenza
where
we were talking about spanish flu it
wasn't in spain really it was in france
and
germany and britain but it's called
spanish because spain was a neutral
country in the first world war
and therefore um the the military
and the censorship and the countries at
war meant they couldn't talk about their
military
strength being wiped out by flu that
more people
died of flu in the first world war more
servicemen died of flu in the first war
than
by any reaction which is amazing i only
learned that relatively recently so
when we move forward with the spanish
flu
the first wave killed about five million
people and the second wave 50 million
people so that was just massive which if
you remember well you don't remember nor
do i
the population of the world is a
fraction of what it is yes
50 million people in 1918 is a massive
percentage of the total population if
you take the age group it was tragic
and and so uh that the second wave then
there was a third and fourth wave
and it's to do with the fact that winter
came along
and because flu's a winter disease
that just produced the right conditions
of the flu
this isn't 1918 we've got better
technology
uh we've got antibiotics now which they
didn't have then
and of course it's covered covered
cov2 which isn't seasonal on the whole
it's
it's constant throughout so we're not so
worried about it in winter
we are worried about of course getting
overwhelmed by
winter pressures which is due to flu
coming at the same time
if we can't get rid of the cov2
if you look at countries that are a
little bit further along so
there's there are three countries that
opened up
at mid-april 14th of april
and that was austria czech republic and
and denmark they all opened
that time when i say open their open
schools open
pubs restaurants all this stuff and we
look at what's happened there
it there has been a rise but rather like
here it's a slow rise and it's now
coming down
again and the predictors is that they've
got away with it without
certainly no second wave in
hospitalization which is the key thing
that's all that matters
uh in reality especially if the rise
is due to better testing and more
frequent tests
picking up people can i put to your
hypothetical and it will take some time
to sort of set out but
we've said that the initial lockdown
that we've had and
the other responses were a bit of an
overreaction i think that's fair to say
if there is contrary to your predictions
which we believe
but but if if you if you're not right
and there is a second wave
what would be the appropriate response
to that given everything that
we have talked about with francis where
it's hard to say
what's done more damage curvy does a
lockdown what would be the right
reaction
in that situation as long as the
hospitalizations are not going up as
long as people are not getting out we
just carry on just keep everything open
keep the schools open
keep workplace open obviously pubs shops
restaurants
normal life goes on uh and you know ev
every week or two we're adding to it
we're adding the risk i mean
probably the last thing to go is
spectator sports
and things like opera i mean just
because you're
generating aerosol when people sing and
you've got a crowd in front of you
similarly if you play at wembley a
football match
with a crowd you're generating a lot of
people shouting standing
up and so and you can't get away from
that you can hardly ask the audience to
shut up because there's no shouting
you're gonna wear a plaster around your
mouth for the whole of the match
so uh so we have this ridiculous vision
of football when you've got artificial
applause i mean it's absolutely
ridiculous to what to watch and listen
to
so uh and sometimes it gets out of sync
with where the ball is that's the
strangest thing
but but i think moving forward uh
what will happen is that society has
already got used to it
people of all ages have got used to it
there's an extreme with older people
a lot of people are frightened and
that's partly the government's form they
frightened them right at the beginning
but this protect the nhs which was
unnecessary
and that means they're too frightened
still to go back to normal society and
we've got to get back to normal
and but again you get the gloom and doom
merch at the time you see them
everywhere and good morning
britain and itv morning television
daytime television
i've been on a couple of times now and
their resident doctor
he's always predicting in two weeks
they'll be the second wave he said that
a month ago and luckily it's not
but let's say that there is and there
are more hospitalizations and we start
to see that coming back
what should the government do in that
situation okay so
that would be the doomsday scenario yes
which if hospitalizations go up icu
admissions go up
85 000 deaths happen just like the
gloomy
epidemiologist's prediction we would
have to take action now can we do it
without lockdown
that's the question can we just blast
away sweden did it without any longer
well
it's not true they did it without
lockdown they did it with social
distancing and they did it with
hand washing and all those and sweden is
a very
very disciplined country i mean the
whole of scandinavia is very disciplined
um we're not so disciplined we're we're
freer spirits i guess
and we're more revolting against
the sort of things we've been talking
about we don't like it and so
uh imagine if you really locked down
this part of london and put the
roadblocks up you'd object
you can't get out of your flat you can't
leave your studio
this would be terrible so i think what
will happen
if we do get a lot of hospitalization
there will be a sort of balance it will
never be as bad as it was
in april march april but we may see
some now the other thing we may see is
local
more serious local lockdown what's
curious the leicester which is well
being
well studied now not a blip in hospital
admissions in leicester so
you can see the classic dome-shaped
curve for
infection in leicester going up going
right down again now
and look at hospital admission just flat
throughout the whole thing
so totally different if you look at
leicester way back in
in in march and april when the missions
went
up and the numbers went up so something
different happens i
i think it's a hypothetical question as
you say constant theme but it's likely
that it's not going to happen but if it
did happen we'd have to reconsider the
strategy i mean polishes would have to
look
and how they could do some sort of local
shift in policy
and carol i know that you are not a
psychiatrist
um but i i do want to talk about how it
is
yes you want some personal help yeah i
do i'm a comedian we're all
unhinged to one degree or another but we
don't seem to be talking about mental
health enough when it when it comes to
the lockdown
i feel yeah and the impact it has had on
people and
the public as a whole i read a stat that
apparently
according to the national office of
statistics that
depression has more than doubled what
one of the problems with mental health
and you know we do ridiculous small
amounts when you're a medical student
then you forget it until something
happens that you've got a mad patient
and you're stuck trying to work out what
to do
the problem with mental health it's so
difficult to measure the severity so
a great example someone comes i'm
depressed doctor
so what do i do how do i measure how
serious this person is or someone says
i want to kill myself so you get into
the suicide conversation so
how can you assess is it serious i
remember it was a lady
about when i was a young doctor i did
general practice for
several weekends and i'd go out and the
lady about to jump off a build from the
the high ledge on a uh above a pub in
whitefall
the the white cross the silver cross the
silver crossing whale
and i phoned up 999 because you know i
couldn't handle it myself and this well
how serious is it
i thought she's sitting on the ledge
i've been called to the doctor and we
need to get help we need to get an
ambulance probably the fire brigade here
so but it's very difficult to assess how
serious and when you say depression has
gone up
if you ask people how do you feel today
you give them a scale
and a linear analog scale mark here or
number of smiles on a
thing so there's a number of smiles lots
of smiles you're not depressed
or the other way around lots of sad
faces you're depressed lots of happy
faces you're not depressed
um it's a very crude measurement of the
reality of depression
but i think very good indicators of
suicide rate going on that's pretty
extreme
child abuse going up because it is a
form of mental aberration if you like
it's not normal family
to to beat children up or to harm
children
and then the other thing is how many
people actually got admitted to
mental institutions section the
compulsory detention
and much fewer and the reason for that
of course because the whole system was
broken
people didn't weren't called
psychiatrists weren't called
psycho psychosocial workers weren't uh
psychiatric
social workers weren't called to to go
and section people so
again when this is all over uh probably
not till september
um it may not be over in september
we are you're right i was forgetting
we've moved on when when i say when it's
over when we can actually collect all
the data
just like cancer you can look at mental
health for the nation
and look through it and what will be
fascinating is to compare it with other
countries to start looking at the same
thing
in other countries who've handled it
differently the timing's been
differently
the enforcement's been different and you
know i have a granddaughter that lives
in peru
and that's the military police state
it's strictly enforced you can't go out
without a permit and that sort of thing
people stop you
and you get fined if you do and so we've
never had that here
and that generates its own mental health
problems essentially feeling locked up
for six months is not a good feeling
and but uh yeah so that's all
that's the problem with mental health
and
there's also a question that we talk
about stats and data we talk about
excess deaths but then
it it came to the fall that actually the
data that has been used by everybody
isn't
even reliable i think the worst one's
been the deaths you know um
public health england which has met its
own demise over this whole issue
it was only pointed out two months ago
that the
death figures were greatly exaggerated
and it was a simple error
and what they were doing if you'd been
tested positive you were flagged up on
one register
as positive and then if you died and the
computer matched the two
wherever you've had your test and
positive you were called a coveted death
if you walked down the hospital having
been tested positive got hit by a bus
you die from code if you died of
terminal cancer
uh you died with an axe in your head
because your wife didn't like you
you're talking about my future there
yeah exactly you got all these things
and and so the number it was ridiculous
and so then they tried to say well let's
do it
60 days after testing positive and then
so there was
the 60-day death and then they made it
28 days which is much more realistic
if you tested positive you died within
28 days it doesn't get you out from
being run over by a bus but it's less
likely it's more likely to be covered
than
other things but none of it was based
and no one understood that
even the health minister didn't
understand that when he was quoting
these deaths
they weren't based on reality and at one
point
at four weeks ago they had to change the
number downwards it was embarrassing it
was appeared on the wa show website
and it said britain forty six thousand
uh
a week ago and now only forty one
thousand of this
so wherever the the five thousand gone
well they'll wrongly
attributed to kovit that was a little
byline there
so measurement is key because if we are
going to make comparisons
france germany switzerland uh sweden
and us we need to make sure we're
comparing apples with apples and not
apples and oranges so we've got to get
these numbers
the same with the infection rate we've
got to make sure we're comparing the
same thing
and you know if you go and collect
people in london where the infection
rate
is probably about one in sixty thousand
of us has it so you
you never find someone one is sixty
thousand the chance of finding someone
this afternoon down the commercial road
that has covered is almost zelda
um but if we go to an area where you
know there's a lot of people that are
positive just in the last few days
then you're much more likely to find it
there maybe one in every 20 people scott
cove
so put no swabs up collect saliva you'll
find it so
it's a it can bias the numbers
in whichever way you want to so
looking at everything that's happened
there's been mistakes makes there's been
good
decisions made what do you think should
be the lessons learned
that we have so far from this whole
episode
i think the first lesson is to
strengthen public health
communication i i had no idea
as a as a consultant that this was
really going on until about february
and i thought it would just blow away i
mean i i couldn't believe what happened
in the end
and and so we've got to prepare for the
same thing happening again
in exactly the same way and we've got to
prepare for it in a way
that doesn't involve lockdown can we do
it without locking down
all services and including health
services can we do it in a way that
maintains the emergency function for
an infection without closing down the
system
the second thing is is much better
public education about what to do
and uh and then the third thing
is the politicians probably should stay
out of it i mean
it was dominated by the boris you know
these
boris or some other deputy of boris is
standing there in the center
flanked by his undertaker's uh chris
whitley and
and the chief scientists often and
dressed in
in black suits and black ties as though
they're the executioners of the country
and i think it's not a political thing
it's a just you needs one guy to take
control of it and say this is the
spokesman for the medical professional i
actually felt she did in the states
although him and trump are
just bizarre to watch as trump is a
bizarre character
but i think i think that's the way
forward
and uh you know the health service
really should have kept going for
everything else throughout the whole
thing
and you know and then you get things
like
19 girls which were based on the gloomy
predictions of the
epidemiologists and proved to be a
complete
waste of time oh sure 40 patients were
admitted to the one in
east near here in excel but that was
just tokenism to show it could be done
and even that project wasn't thought
through but where you're going to get
the staff from you're going to have to
take them from existing hospital you're
not going to recruit staff in the time
frame to suddenly open it
staff with the limiting factor in health
care has always been so
always will so a question that a lot of
ordinary people will be asking
is when do we get back to normal
and i don't mean new normal i mean
normal
where we meet we shake hands we don't
wear you know
masks to go to a supermarket and then
you walk out of the supermarket go into
a pub
and you're fine to sit with people like
all of these things that don't make any
sense
right when do we get back to actual
normal
my prediction is first of january we'd
be back to normal when you can get rid
of everything no
social distancing all those silly signs
that really
go on the london transport i mean they
put a lot of effort into it you know
they've had to but you know i think it's
an overreaction
uh you know if the virus is on that tube
it's gonna get you with your two meters
or five meters
as the tube's crowded you're going to
get the virus if it's there
so i think january is the time to
new year new vision new normal yeah
sounds great but what would do you think
we need to see in terms of the data yeah
to facilitate because putting a date on
it is sort of like
arbitrary isn't it whereas i think it i
guess
a more interesting way of looking at
might be what needs to happen with the
virus
in order for us to feel comfortable
doing obviously number one would be a
vaccine
yeah if we get that that sort of takes
care of it is that
broadly accurate and with this guff flu
i mean is not necessarily the answer
because firstly it may take longer than
we think
yeah it's got to be completely safe
before any of the regulators allow it
otherwise they'll be
pummeled if it causes some bizarre
neurological degenerative syndrome for
example that doesn't sound good no but
they get cold exactly this is one of the
complications of virus
of vaccines especially they're not fully
tested
but more importantly it's not work for
the flu really and it's not work for
for sales so it may not work for this in
a way
we hope that we it'll have partial
immunity but it'll help
but it may not be the only solution the
the effort to vaccinate
millions of people is quite significant
but i think by january it will be in a
much better place
as long as the hospitalization stayed
down we could experiment we could start
removing things like
the the masks and like the
the social distancing but hand washing
is not a bad idea
the shaking hands if you wash your hands
then it's fine you know
so i think we'll get back to normal
quicker than we think
and people will stop being scared what i
find amazing is children
uh six grandchildren i look at them and
talk to them
they're not frightened about it they're
they're fine well they're pretty much
yeah exactly they've got no reason to be
afraid but
some of them would be locked up you know
yeah yeah oh yeah and so
but they they haven't a better
understanding the children are much more
adaptable than we are yeah
in wartime children just went through it
bombs going off and no problem
i mean some of them had psychological
scars but they tolerated it and
people from warsaw and to dance which
whereas uh
yeah and what do you what do you think
about
the new zealand's position and that
they've taken extreme lockdowns
the moment we got they got four cases i
think it was everything shut literally
everything
france has been wanting to close the
borders
but no do do you agree with that that
that approach
or do you see it as being a huge
overreaction i think that's a huge
overreaction
i mean they they they're now getting
cases because cases are coming and
and that's the problem uh i haven't
looked at the new zealand philippines
for the last two weeks but i i gather
that they're bouncing back a bit because
they get people coming whether they're
legal or not legal they come
and the figures start going up um the
countries that
if you if you look at the the countries
of the world they've all had slightly
different strategies but
the trouble is how firm
was the policy of not admitting people
from abroad
returning residents have always been
allowed back so if you're in new zealand
and you come back from somewhere
you're allowed in and that maybe you may
have to quarantine but
how effective is that warranty if you
want to do it properly
you've got to take people straight off
the plane into a camp rather that the
people
remember the pictures at the very
beginning of all this people coming from
um where were they coming from now they
were coming from wuhan
they were coming from china and they
were bust from bryze norton to the
milton keynes to accommodation in
northern keynes
and kept there for two weeks and that
was before they had any compulsory
detention
laws and that was the first we saw of it
seemed like years ago yeah it does so
how firm your quarantine is how firm
you're policing of the border
and if you allow residents in who knows
what's going to happen that's what's
probably happened in new zealand
because it's also as well is that we
don't know that how long the virus has
been here
so for instance i was still a teacher in
in the december time and i remember
around about january this there was a
thread on twitter with
assistant heads and head teachers
talking about having covered like
symptoms
and we we discussed ourselves about i
think i had it in mid-february i had all
the symptoms
there was a case in france in december
yeah wasn't there and
there were cases in france there's even
cases in november
in at a shooting party in worcestershire
believe it or not
really was wiltshire yeah and uh
there were three cases out of six people
that stayed in a big country house
and they've proven positive i mean how
it all arose and how it spreads the most
likely scenario
arose in wuhan somehow whether it was
do you have any unorthodox thoughts on
the origins of the virus
yeah you mean it was an escape from the
laboratory yeah
it was a weaponized virus it was a
research program to weaponize the virus
it escaped probably accidentally because
viruses do escape
people break the safety rules and don't
wear gloves or don't wet whatever you
need to wear
and the virus got out and then you know
i like to think
it's it's a luxury virus it went
straight down the airport road to the
first class lounge
and then went fully first class around
the world's little friends all these
little viruses said goodbye
with their little suitcases and went off
and they went first class because they
could meet fat people they could meet
rich people
they could meet people that were old
because older people can travel
because they have more money than the
young and they shifted it
and before we finish the one thing i'd
really like to say because it reminds me
of
that one of the economic consequences
that the mainstream media don't bring
out is this business of generational
theft which has now been increased the
generational theft comes people my age
had free education completely
my kids had free yet more or less free i
think i just caught a thousand pound
fear yes
university education for the youngest
and
then we've had house prices that every
time my first house got 12 000 pounds
imagine that
get out
and you know you sell it for sixty
thousand pounds then you get the next
one yeah
seventy thousand and then you sell that
for you know two hundred yeah
so it goes it goes on up so all my
generation
to a different and we've had and and end
scheme pensions and
final year pensions whereas your
generation is not going to have that
it's not possible and what happens with
covid of course it disproportionately
affects the younger people
whose education has been stopped younger
than you
education's been abruptly stopped and
there are just going to be no jobs to
get started so all those graduates that
are
out there a lot of them are not going
that were promised internships they may
get their internship because it's free
they may get the
the sunac scholarships or whatever they
call it from government
but they're not going to have a proper
job so with that in mind then
before we ask our last question should
we
have done and should we in the future in
a similar situation
shield the vulnerable shield the elderly
and allow the rest of society to get on
as with their lives as normal is that
the right solution here that
that seems a good solution i think
you've got to
give a free choice to people you this
it's educational messages if you're
over 70 consider your health for example
are you if you're a fit active 70 year
old just be
carry about your business but remember
you are at greater risk than if you were
50
and that it's up to you what you decide
to do not
to try and reinforce it not to say every
if you know 70 year olds on the street
we shoot at the site
shoot to kill
and that's the the way forward uh uh
and and that that protects them and so
the others can
act whatever do whatever they want
because they're not likely to be
seriously damaged so if the young
person's on chemotherapy for example for
cancer then they should be
prepared to protect themselves by
isolating from
the rest but it's mainly about avoiding
crowds where you don't control
your meeting so going to a shop is you
have no control on social distance
whereas
in your garden you have perfect control
and social distance
and thank you so much for coming on the
show it's proved incredibly enlightening
uh the last question we always finish
with is uh what is the one thing we're
not talking about
as a society that we really should be so
we're not talking about death
and uh western society never talks about
death
and it it's become even more difficult
with the demise of religion of organized
religion so
organized religion church of england
whatever not just christianity but all
the religions
um at the moment we sort of blank it out
of our lives there is no end to it we're
going to go on forever we're eternal
beings
and i think that's what we've seen with
this you know
i've got a twitter account as you know
and
if i mention death it's like a whole
load of bees suddenly come for me saying
or being
unpleasant mentioning death and i guess
doctors are closer to death than most
people if you're a cancer doctor a lot
of your patients are going to die and
that
you have to accept it but i think we
don't talk about it in a meaningful way
and we don't accept it and
i think it's become a failure it's a
failure for the medical establishment if
someone dies
it's a failure for the politicians the
death rate goes up
and i think it's really reflected in the
conversation we've had if the average
age of death is 82 for covert person
then that is actually very close to the
average age of death
in the uk anyway which is 82.3 so
you're not actually taking life away but
look at what we have taken away from
people
so maybe the balance of death is not too
bad a thing
i mean it's now the problem is you get
the argument is our cow you're being
harsh because you know there have been
40 year old people in their prime with
no co-morbidity they've also died
well that's the nature of things if you
cross a road a certain proportion of
people get flattened by the bus coming
by that's always going to happen
you don't close the road because it will
stop the buses traveling so
it's getting a balance of risk in that
but death has
got to become an acceptable outcome for
people
it is in hospices that's the only place
it is uh it's not in
out there in society this is such a good
point i'm glad you make that point
because i feel like
on a lot of the response to this virus
the thinking has been very
one-dimensional very one-dimensional
uh will will will will save lives as the
slogan was
but how many lives are now affected by
the other things and i'm really glad
we've had a chance to discuss that with
you
uh professor cora thank you so much for
coming on if people want to follow
your commentary the things that you're
putting uh where do they go to find that
prof carousaura on twitter and
two or three a day is about the most i
can make yeah
fantastic well thank you very much for
coming on and thank you for watching we
will see you
very soon with another live stream or
episode and they all go out
at 7 00 p.m we play time take care and
see you soon guys bye-bye
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the youtube channel
click the bell button next to subscribe
button so you get notified when a video
comes out
and follow us on all the social media at
trigger pod
and also leave us a nice review on
itunes and spread